we might be drunk
we
might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
i'll tell you we're back here guys
you're all right you guys you're right
yeah patreon folks the real deal fans
you guys are right on the ground floor
we're back baby oh yeah we're back we're
back with your questions emails peeves
tweets queefs whatever you got here
we're on it remember it's we might be
drunk pod at gmail.com we love you guys
for reaching out uh if you want to be
part of the patreon it's patreon.com we
might be drunk pod it's growing like
crazy yeah we got different tiers not
just not just eyeball tiers we're
talking
you want to put this much you get that
thing you get this a postcard you get a
your name on the wall uh sam will blow
you whatever it is we got more tears and
creamer versus kramer i'll tell you
we're all right you know
oh yeah
well you didn't like white lotus i
didn't interesting i made it one episode
i i'm i i'm a fan of mike white it just
didn't
i didn't grab you
no it didn't interesting i couldn't it
the balance didn't work for me
personally i i
am a fan of mike white though yeah i
think he's good you know what he's great
at and i thought the ending was weak and
he got a lot of criticism for it but
he's a he's a genius writer but
what he does is social commentary he
puts it in there he peppers it in so
subtly that you don't even know you're
seeing social you thought that was
subtle
well you didn't even finish it all right
you got to finish it yes i was i read
about what happened i know what happens
okay well it's the journey if i told you
the score the next game at the end you'd
be like exactly so what i know but i
watched the pilot and the pilot just
like i kind of was like this i i if you
give me nothing that does anything for
me in the pilot i can't it's it's 60
minutes of my time man
i think that's fair but i mean the the
wire pilot took me three tries and then
i loved it wires top five shows ever i
know but it took it took a lot i know
but you're comparing this to the top
five shows i like look there's too many
shows that's the truth of it so if you
don't grip me at all in the pilot i just
i got no i got no knock on it people
love it it just wasn't for me i'm not
saying it was a bad show even i'm just
saying it didn't
yeah not everything i get that not
everything's for you i i uh
i turned to my lady friend and she was
like i said i don't like this and she
goes thank god i can't stand this either
so i was like all right all right i mean
it was like one of the things where
i love a lot of succession's my favorite
show on hbo comes back in october i know
season i told my agents you got one job
and it's to get me an audition
[ __ ] succession can you please i'll
two lines i just want to be on the show
to me it's like got that sopranos type
of like oh yeah dark humor that i i love
yes my dad likes succession my dad hates
everything including me
so
but i said the same thing to my agent i
said get me a curb audition and he got
me one and i didn't get it so that's on
me
but yeah well at least he got you he got
me one succession to me is like
it it's as good as it gets is like funny
i mean dramatic peep show jesse
armstrong great great that's who wrote
it what yeah it's the peep show guy
peep show is like the funniest show ever
what did he write put that together
is that right that's true look it up
what that's what you got a [ __ ]
laptop for
get on it sloppy jalopy
you think you think this is a game solid
keys you think i'm [ __ ] with you dude
not a game it's my life
varsity blues
all right what do you got hold on
i don't want your laugh that was varsity
blues oh yeah that [ __ ] turd
[Laughter]
he's a movie john boyd all right hold on
i liked it i didn't like it oh yeah it's
a turd but i liked it what was the fat
guy's name boss hogg or what was it oh
what was that guy billy bob billy bob
there you go that was right for i think
he was in not another teen movie too he
was they just like just be in the actual
movie right right like we can't find a
dude as funny as you
to make fun of this you're fat as [ __ ]
you're 28 perfect for a high school
movie
those high school kids are all 29 32
every time every time yeah so [ __ ]
weird pete old rich is in high school
what are we doing here i never never was
a big fan
he had a moment he had a scream and he
said he was good and screaming i take it
and he wasn't uh as good as it gets
he was the robber i hated him as good as
it gets yeah he nearly killed greg
kinnear
yes as good as it gets you can nev you
can never make a movie like that
nowadays what do you mean it's all
dialogue well he's racist in it and he's
homophobic and likable and likeable good
point
you can't make a movie where the
character is multifaceted in that way
that's so true all in the family now the
whole movie would be like my dad's
racist
yeah
the movie would call my dad's a [ __ ]
racist that's a great point i never
thought that's a great point yeah you
couldn't do it i'm gonna die you're
gonna die sure sounds like your son's
gonna die
[Laughter]
helen hunts uh jesse armstrong wet
t-shirt by the way gosh the guy
[ __ ] do i stutter oh [ __ ] that's
offensive to people who stutter
get helen hunt in the the rain while
you're over there as good as it gets
[ __ ] classy oh i love that movie god
bless james l brooks that was letting uh
jack nicholson be jack nicholson for an
hour and a half and we all loved it
there it is yeah is jack nicholson the
greatest movie star the last 50 years
who's better he might be he might be
i mean tom hanks is up there
who's more hero
by the way you can argue as a better
actor you can't argue he's a better
movie star that's the thing is is he's
wow look at this
nicholson was a [ __ ] joker dude
i know and he cleaned up on that one but
de niro i don't know i go de niro over
nicholson but
nicholson is holding
stuff nicholson has the aura he's got
the mystique he's got the sunglasses at
the lakers game okay so my point is de
niro is more of a chameleon but
nicholson is more of a movie star he's
more of a movie star i'll give you that
de niro sucks off stage nicholson is
awesome off stage yeah
de niro just movies i like it's like
hoffman it's pacino it's de niro it's
just that run that 70s run yeah those
are my guys but okay but five easter
eggs okay seventies run okay uh
chinatown one more of the cuckoo's nest
cuckoo's it's a good run give me give me
a third one five easy pieces it's not
great easy ride easy rider [ __ ]
that's 60s but okay i'll take it i got
that okay midnight cowboy and graduate
or 60s [ __ ]
okay oh we're not we're either playing
with the 60s or all right i'm
now we're going with the 80s let's talk
about the shining oh it's so shining
that's the that's let's talk about
batman [ __ ] okay let's talk
about range show me some any range
he doesn't have the range the other guys
do that's important can do everything
okay where's the last guy what's the
last good dustin hoffman performance
besides miowitz stories
oh
okay let me go to the imdb
nicholson's got the departed
[ __ ]
yeah but that wasn't great the part is
great i like it but it's not a great
movie it's a good movie dude and that
whole thing with like oh the you know
the rats in here you can smell the
cheese
like all right all right oh ridiculous
we watched that movie and told me it's
not funny i love the movie i've seen it
800 times but also his his accent was
bad too
when i tell you to bury him in the mash
you bury him in the mash like ah you
can't do an accent i'm sorry i love your
nickels and you can't do it okay uh one
wonderful of the cougar's nest is as
good as a performance as ever
chinatown's just cool
[Music]
okay he's got nothing
what who hoffman's got enough yeah
[ __ ] i told you what is that
a lot of [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] movies
it was fun in [ __ ] but yeah again
it's not acting then kung fu panda a lot
of people that's a pay cheque
i'm leaving out some good niggles in
movies he has some good flex blood and
wine was pretty cool in the 90s he had
some good flicks he did like as good as
it gets is great softcore porn for a
minute too
nicholson yeah yeah it basically was a
soft core i can't think of the name what
was it it might have been kathleen
turner and him
you know it's a great kathleen turner
flick
body heat dude body heat one of the
she's one of the
best yeah
uh william hurt great great dialogue
what about wolf wolf took him down a
pick also nicholson hasn't been in
anything since 2010. he's old he doesn't
need it he's [ __ ] still
him crap kicking
niro's still kicking as well yeah
yeah nicholson's [ __ ] old he did a
lot of coke give him a break man he
[ __ ] everybody too oh yeah mars
attacks that was fun it wasn't that good
no but he's fun enough i've seen a few
times i liked it too okay a few good men
[ __ ] oh yeah you can't handle
the truth there's more to see guys join
the patreon right now at patreon.com we
might be drunk get on the after party i
think i just broke this
there you go you get emails tell us your
wrecks your jokes your drinks we'll open
boxes you're missing out folks all the
good stuff's on the patreon tell a
friend